on termine avec une belle initiative ça
fait du bien du jour elle vient de
suisse et elle pourrait intéresser les
familles françaises
une remorque un contenaire qui voyagent
avec une belle pièce aménagée dédié
notamment aux personnages âgées aux
personnes âgées pardon ces dernières
peuvent retrouver leur famille en toute
sécurité une baie vitrée est en seine et
au milieu pas de prise de risque donc
les mesures de distanciation sociales
sont respectés et le contact et donc
renoué après des semaines et des mois
d'inquiétude
également appelée happy day room ce
concept a été créé dans le cadre d'une
émission rapideye diffuser cinq fois par
an sur la télévision suisse
et pour en parler nous sommes avec rémy
fabrique un président directeur général
de team cosmo zurich bonsoir et me
fabriquer merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france comment vous est venue cette
cette idée de boîte
bonjour madame d'abord ben j'ai été
contacté par la modératrice de rebih d
une des mes amis qui connaissez mon
projet avec un avec ce conteneur qui
était déjà fait si con et de ce côté-là
été au centre d'une campagne
d'engagement que j'avais conçu par la
campagne de mazda il ya des ans après
l'avoir eue avec le producteur de
l'émission il était clair que je vais le
reconstruire et nous utiliserons pour
évider alors comment sont-elles conçu
est ce qu'elles peuvent voyager à
travers le pays par exemple
ben oui on court on l'a mis soient
mobiles ces boîtes le elles peuvent
voyager à travers donc le pays ont visé
oui alors ces boîtes sont mobiles nous
étions maintenant à neuf endroits nous
mettons le continent sera charger
surbaissé et nous pouvons l'utiliser à
travers la suisse et ne se diriger
chaque destination
alors on imagine que ça a créé 2 2
des émules peut-être d'autres pays vous
ont contacté parce qu'on sait que c'est
une citation situation extrêmement
compliquée notamment pour les personnes
âgées
la réponse au spectacle a été énorme sur
tous les commentaires sur les canaux
sociales ont montré le besoin des
familles de se revoir
nous aimons le faire car les conditions
sont les mêmes partout et nous avons
fait un projet mobile maintenant pour du
simple et moins cher et nous recherchons
des sponsors
alors justement pour l'instant comment
sont-elles financez vous dites vous
chercher des sponsors ça veut dire qu'il
ya des appels un petit peu vous vous
appeler aux pouvoirs publics par exemple
oui en suisse nous aurait été financée
par match à la télévision suisse
mais pour les pays étrangers nous
recherchons des sponsors tels que les
bandes des compagnies d'assurance ou dit
cécile société des télécommunications
dont le but de leur communication d'être
là pour les gens de l'action est plus
crédible que de faire des publicités qui
prétend seulement être là pour les gens
merci beaucoup rémy fabrique un d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous